I know whom her new BFF is and I can't
tell you I can't but I can I promise you
it's it's brilliant and unexpected and
just so good
I think mantises strikes us BFF for sure
I think mantis and Drax just have a
special connection we carried that over
from the last film on to Avengers and
you'll see you'll see that they're just
constantly like joined at the hip which
is great when I first read the script
guardians to I never saw the interaction
between tracks and mantis as being
anything even possibly romantic it
seemed more like a brotherly sisterly
thing to me and that's the way I looked
at it as far as performance but a lot of
people kind of really felt like there
were some vibes there what we're not a
couple we're friends no no but that's
why I love working with James so much
you know he makes everything so original
and so unique you know and the
relationship that we have between you
know mantis and Drax
it's like friendship you know it's like
he's like an older brother in a way I
think palm and I have really great
chemistry on film but here's my thing
here's my problem with that is that I
don't think Drax could ever get over the
loss of his wife and his daughter I
don't think he could ever get past that
I I've always said that I would really
love for people to have a visual
reference of Jackson's family to kind of
see why he's so heartbroken and see how
much he actually loved them so I hope
they tell a little bit of that backstory
at least people get kind of a glimpse of
his wife and daughter I think that's
really kind of the center of who drex's
and what keeps him going
I just I don't know if you could ever
love
another woman like that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]